you need to really dig into my music
career bro like I'm responsible for a
lot of these cats well that's right like
honestly like it's so hard for me to
keep up with everything and the base
[__] is so like
I try my best to be as engaged as
possible but there's a lot of [__] what
do you get your love from the background
just I think just living growing up on
the west coast and then like as a little
kid my dad's favorite rapper was too
short so I was listening to [__] Too
Short in the clips Spice One all that
[__] and so like and I also like a
student of the game so like I will see
like
the influence of like certain [__] you
know like and just be like damn the bay
really got so much sauce and just for
whatever reason always is just passed
over yeah or like just a little
disrespected or not necessary and like
you said it I do feel like there is a
lot of that with the bay where it is a
crabs in the barrel mentality with a lot
of artists out there right so um I just
had YG and tiger right
they were in Oakland right yeah West
Oakland dog town okay let's get this
right is that where they shot the video
with the blast record
no it was a different record it was like
a record with just tiger and YG on there
and uh I think it was called going
platinum and uh you know they tapped in
shout out Dave oh they typed in I'll
bring them out there no beautiful day
um
a lot of people um enjoyed theyself you
know they were very cool they taking
pictures with the fans shaking hands
kissing babies and then bam
all these cats oh y'all dick Ryan White
Junior y'all doing this y'all got them
[__] in Oakland and Blah Blah's like
[__] like right now that you know these
guys are Mega Stars there's been people
and females listening to these guys for
since they were in school and just like
yeah like the city's gonna be in the
music video is gonna get love like this
is like something to kind of help bro
why not show up and try to network yeah
and the people who was there it was
beautiful they bought all these cars out
um they really showed the culture you
get what I'm saying and then for our own
people to like just like hate on that
[__] that [__] was disgusting to me like
this make people not even want to come
[__] with y'all and y'all wonder why
we're not on or why we not in certain
positions and [__] like that because now
that they come they love the hospitality
we show them hell of a great time but
it's like now they gotta go back and
watch their names being tarnished on the
internet even though people don't give a
[__] about it but [__] not
necessary
if YG and tiger came to Phoenix and
tried a music video everybody'd be so
happy they'd be like this is amazing
yeah you feel me right right right right
right right but I mean but but also I
mean I get it like I think that like
like you said like I think that like
I feel like when you're kind of like not
on purposely maybe undervalued or
underappreciated in the grand culture of
California and Hip-Hop like you might
have a a a
what am I trying to say
uh not rock on your shoulder what's the
what's the saying I'm trying to say I
don't know I'm lost what is it
trip on your shoulder the [__]
um but yeah because I feel like a lot of
that kind of also happen when like Drake
did the motto right right for sure I
wish he would have put a barrier artist
on the remix right right yeah for sure
that would have been dope you know but
again like
it was it was a moment at that time
sneak or something just somebody yeah it
could have been 40. could have been
whoever I really wish that there would
have been a model remix because I think
the only remix there was was a tiger
remix
oh yeah which made no sense to me
because I'm like yo you got to put
somebody on for me so you're really into
the bay area like you know you kind of
yeah yeah for sure
hey whoever came out of Arizona like
doing the music
why is he laughing bro
he's from Arizona too I mean we had uh
MC Magic
don't know who the [__] that is shout
out to MC Magic though so he's a Mexican
artist who's very popular
he's a legend he's a legend for sure
shout out to MC Magic uh we have he's
the biggest
guy named futuristic who had like a
little independent run that was good he
did on Jimmy Fallon show Once
we had uh then there was like this wave
where Ludacris signed Willie North Pole
to dtp
the game sign juice who now goes by
Richie Evans the 50 Cent has some guy
who blew it up well 50 signed a guy
named hot rod hot rod yeah hot rod had a
record with Mary J Blige called be easy
but hot rod is really from Sacramento oh
he's not from Arizona so he when he when
he signed a G Unit like he was living in
Arizona at the time he was a part of a
crew called the man up Squad and it was
cool you know but
I don't think we like really like he
still lives in Arizona but he wasn't
like an AZ guy right he was from Sac one
dot one guy he had that record body
marked up really North Pole that was
that's really North Pole who signed with
Luda put it he put an album out probably
the biggest deal we've ever had was
woolly North Pole put an album out
through Def Jam and dtp that I got I
actually got to go to the store and buy
okay okay which is like a big deal is he
still around like he's still I mean he's
I don't think he's making much music but
he's still around okay he's a legend you
know um this is one guy I just heard of
as of recently
um he was messing with slim 400 desert
Baby Desert baby I think he might be
like is Desert baby still incarcerated
yeah free free desert baby okay and then
uh Riley you ever heard of Riley Riley's
Riley is my boy's boy yeah I got a song
with Riley blood shout out Riley blood
see I'm typing yeah he's a good guy yeah
yeah and like right now there's like
Chris Coke there's mercums Riley there's
uh who else is popping [__] in AZ uh
Jada pink and stuff there's like a dope
bubbling scene right now I was like
question
I'm talking to you I'm interviewing you
yeah but look why um why you think AZ
haven't had they shot very much crabbing
the barrel mentality very much so
probably I mean it's terrible do you
support it though you're from Asia you
like to have the biggest figures for
sure yeah I've had everybody come in
freestyle on my show I think that um
I think that with these smaller markets
sometimes it's very easy to get wrapped
up in pointing your finger at everybody
else as to why your [__] ain't doing
what you should be doing so I always
tell artists like hey man you got to
take a [__] in your own hands like you
got to build fan bases that are in the
independent of you having
I mean I hate to break it to everybody
but getting your [__] played on the
radio don't make a difference right
right
and I tell people that all the time
Instagram shout out don't mean [__]
either they don't mean nothing it's like
bro you need people to buy into you you
need to build that catalog you need to
formulate your sound you need to figure
out how you're going to turn five fans
to ten and 10 into 20 over and over stop
because a lot of times like I'll get
people like man the [__] bootleg Kev he
ain't put me on his [__] and I'm like
bro like
I I always tell people just because
you're from Phoenix don't mean you just
get to come on my [__] right I gotta
just like be a fan of what you're doing
I gotta [__] see what you're doing
and I gotta be like oh [__] okay yeah
pull up and I've had hella people from
Arizona motion hella people but it's
just a matter of like I think with a lot
of those smaller markets that tends to
be the cases those are crab in the
barrel cities unfortunately because
there isn't nobody knows better we
haven't had somebody really pop to be
like oh that's how it's done all right
right you know what I mean and I think a
lot of the guys who end up making this
[__] work on a bigger scale kind of
leave for a little bit and I think
that's with anywhere you know sometimes
you got to get out of your your comfort
zone and I also think too that um
once somebody start getting a little bit
of like they turn their nose up for sure
yeah oh he switched up all right well
what do you mean okay what are you
saying like but yeah I think I think
Arizona's a definitely crabbing the
mentality uh it's getting better and a
lot of people are working with each
other now and it's definitely um
you know because what Arizona I just
know it's Phoenix
uh Tucson so Tucson's an hour away I
know right uh we really don't
consider them the same
like Tucson and Phoenix there's two big
colleges that are like hardcore Rivals
so Tucson and Phoenix have a [__]
rivalry I'd rather [__] with Tucson
[__] than Phoenix [__] I I feel
you yeah I lost my virginity to a Tucson
[__] see in my dad's truck in Tucson I
met her in an MSN chat room
but the only thing is Tucson it's like
[__] desert is like country Tucson is
a Vibe it's just very small yeah
definitely there's definitely like
you're not gonna The Nightlife sucks
like the people from Tucson not like one
strip club like yeah and the strip
club's weird the last time I went it was
it was not a Vibe I just went oh no I
just when I went to Tucson
it's a bar town like yeah I mean I've
had fun in Tucson I mean like and like
you said you it's it's you could pull in
Tucson easy right right they're like oh
people are here that aren't from here
like oh look at you they'll get you some
EGS
what isn't that EG's is the name of the
drink they got
yeah it's called EG's yeah Tucson is its
own thing
it's its own thing man two Sean is a t
it's a good tweak but yeah you know all
the Arizona's like hardcore like you
know especially Tucson but so without
Tucson and Phoenix like where do y'all
go in AZ and we're not talking about the
tempees and [__] that's around Phoenix
like Mesa none of that like besides that
it's over with I mean you could go to
Flagstaff [__] Flagstaff who goes to
Flagstaff like what's in Flagstaff you
could snowboard uh there's Sedona which
is beautiful
go to Sedona and trip trip balls it's
like a bunch of spiritual vortexes and
[__] and let me show you Sedona is
[__] beautiful so
okay where would Drake do a show at
besides Phoenix to Arizona Tucson
besides Tucson
oh okay it's all a bunch of red rocks
and [__] right right no they're nowhere
else
maybe Flagstaff maybe at NAU maybe at
the college okay but now
there's Phoenix Arizona is literally
Phoenix right and then a bunch of just
Tiny Places I mean Tucson's a cool
Tucson's cool it's not like a [__]
hole in the wall it's Phoenix Tucson and
nowhere else
there's Yuma there's the Grand Canyon
which I've never been to and I'm from
Arizona you invite me to your club but
let's talk about that sure whenever I
want to come have a drink and I want to
come you feel me to do the whole
experience I've seen cardi B you feel me
James Harden like what the [__] like I'm
low blood can I come I'm trying to think
the next time I'm I think I'm gonna be
there next weekend
I think we have
we're working on a big booking next week
and I can't say but yeah next weekend
next week I'll be there Saturday between
you want to go to AZ tots
yeah
it's hot right now
how long is that drive it's like 10
hours 12 hours [__] that
ain't [__] yeah